- Aussitôt achetés, aussitôt
sur le marché. Que ce soit
des maisons, des condos ou
des immeubles à logements,
les reventes rapides ont plus
que doublé depuis 2016 dans
le Grand Montréal et se sont
accélérées pendant la pandémie.
L'an dernier, 2800 propriétés
ont changé de main deux fois
en moins de 12 mois.
MARC LEFRANÇOIS, courtier
immobilier, Royal LePage
- Quelqu'un qui flippe
une maison va faire son profit
sur deux éléments : un, sur la
valeur ajoutée qu'il va ajouter
à la propriété, et aussi
le temps que ça va lui prendre.
Si ça prend un an faire ses
travaux, bien, pendant ce temps-
là, il y a un accroissement
de la valeur du marché.
- En rénovant leur propriété,
ils espèrent dégager
des profits qui surpasseront
leurs investissements,
un jeu qui peut être lucratif.
NATHAN LEA,
analyste économique, SCHL
- Vous avez des retours sur
investissement d'à peu près 80 %
pour les unifamiliales.
- Alors que le prix médian
des maisons unifamiliales
a grimpé de 13 % dans l'ensemble
l'an dernier, il a bondi
de 39 %, c'est-à-dire
trois fois plus, pour
les propriétés qui ont fait
l'objet d'une revente rapide.
GENEVIÈVE LANGEVIN, courtière
en immobilier, Royal LePage
- C'est sûr qu'on a des gens
qui commencent, qui vont faire
des petits flips, qui décident
de rénover leur maison puis
de faire un petit coup d'argent,
mais aussi, on a des gens
qui vivent de ça complètement.
- Même si le nombre de reventes
rapides a grandement augmenté,
il demeure somme toute assez
marginal. La cause fondamentale
de la flambée des prix actuelle
demeure l'important déséquilibre
entre l'offre et la demande.
En raison de la pandémie,
plusieurs propriétaires de
maisons ont décidé de reporter
la vente de leur propriété,
mais en même temps, le bassin
d'acheteurs, lui, s'est agrandi.
- L'offre de produits a fait
ça... Puis tout le monde
qui était confiné dans
des petits espaces, à l'inverse,
eux autres, se sont dit :
Bien là, on est en train
de s'étrangler fait qu'on va
aller vers plus grand.
- Il y a beaucoup de demande
pour ce type de propriétés là,
donc les prix ont augmenté,
la rapidité aussi des ventes
s'est fait sentir. Donc c'est
sûr que certaines personnes qui
sont des flippeurs en profitent.
- Si le nombre de transactions
a baissé dans le Grand Montréal
en juin comparativement à l'an
dernier, le nombre de propriétés
mises en vente a diminué encore
plus. Résultat : les prix ont
grimpé de près de 30 % en un an.
Ici Olivier Bachand,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.